my name is Tony and we're here to talk
today about practical ways you can be an
ally for diversity in your workplace it
was about four weeks ago that I got into
a one-sided shouting match with the
former senator Rick Santorum at chicago
o'hare international airport my true
story my husband and i are sitting there
i had just had my trenta iced coffee
from starbucks of course and my
overpriced greasy pizza and I hear
somebody next to me say when I'm elected
president I'm going to roll back some of
the things that have allowed the gays to
destroy American family life you can
imagine the spit take that I did you
know he was getting a radio or
television interview so I let him finish
and then I said how dare you sir how
dare you my husband and I and my family
are sitting right here we're just as
American as you are we're not destroying
anything you have Wow all right I'll
take it okay I mean escalated it's one
side he's a politician so he's used to
people yelling at him he's very slick
about it you know thank you for your
vote okay no so it escalates and I
remind him of the internet meme that
made his name so very very famous and
people around us are either laughing
like you are right now or moving away
because they're afraid they're not going
to get on their flight from the
altercation that could happen I tell you
the story because it's a it's an
indication of the kind of America that I
live in and a lot of LGBT Americans live
in as well right I'm from Boston
Massachusetts a very progressive city
we've had universal health care and
marriage equality for many years now and
I work in new New York Chicago San
Francisco Seattle I live in a bubble
sometimes but then people like Rick
Santorum run for president and they're
giving credibility and they're given
money and they're given a platform in a
stage it's people like him maybe not to
the extreme but people that came in yes
they do live in boston they do live in
seattle they do you live in San
Francisco who think like him that makes
me think twice about coming out at work
every time I start a new job right I'm
trusting
my team members trusting my teammates
and that's where you guys come in that's
where the business comes in here we're
not here to talk about politics we're
here to talk about how you can change
the conversation in your workplace I
came out to you one way the other way I
should come out to use I'm a ruby
developer at a Python conference I am
sorry more Ruby developers okay great we
have a lot in common I think our
communities so more more so than
differences but the third way I'll come
out to is I'm also a manager I manage a
team of engineers over in Boston for a
company called localytics we do mobile
analytics and marketing software for
30,000 apps in the App Store New York
Times NHL soundcloud ESPN our software
is probably on one hundred percent of
your phones right now running in the
background our systems are on two
billion devices around the world our
SDKs and we process billions of events
per day terabytes of data streaming into
our systems we know big data and we deal
with complex systems we just closed our
series defunding 35 million dollars in
funding the most to date of any
TechStars Boston company we're growing
rapidly where one of the fastest-growing
startups in Boston in the country and
I've had to grow the team to measure
Utley the single biggest challenge of
starting a company or growing a
company's attracting the right kind of
people to work for you the systems we're
building are so large one engineer can't
hold them in their head anymore you
probably do with a lot of the same
problems of your work so I need people
that can collaborate people that can
cross over the silos that naturally
happen in a company I need people who
avoid groupthink who offered differing
opinions who trust their co-workers
enough who'd share a lot of their life
with them enough that they feel
confident and comfortable saying I don't
think you're right about that or I think
I have a different perspective on that
that's the kind of team I need to build
and increasingly I think that means
hiring a diverse workforce now diversity
here means of all sorts of gender of
race of socio-economic background of
Education of a
Kate Huddleston a blogger and talker on
the subject has a fantastic formula that
the productivity of my team is a product
of how well they work together times the
sum of their internet of their
individual talent a lot of engineering
departments that I've seen focus on that
some of the talent they try to hire the
most individually talented engineer they
can the person who literally wrote the
book on the language that they're using
and we do hire those people at
localytics we look for that trait of
course the technical bar at Localytics
is very very high as it probably is a
lot of your companies but we don't stop
there the other trait we look for is
teamwork and collaboration how does this
person work with other teams to get work
done I think the best teams are those
that are made up of a diverse set of
opinions group think I'm constantly
worried about this are we sure everyone
that this is the direction we want to go
with this project right there are
studies done by Harvard and others that
show that groups with women in them
groups with a diverse set of backgrounds
solve problems better so we'll talk
about some practical ways at Localytics
we approach this problem we think about
this issue of diversity like a lot of
other companies do we rear essel with it
we're trying to do something about it
until today is a series of antidotes and
things that we're trying out local it
external it's company of course I'm
going to measure everything that i can
write that's my first reaction to things
you've seen companies like Google Yahoo
amazon right they'll publish their their
gender and ethnicity and race makeups
unfortunately I think this is the the
average right eighteen percent women on
their technical teams but they've made
this data public and I love that they've
done so because it makes the problem
very clear not just to their investors
into their employees but to the hiring
managers the people where the rubber
hits the road people who make decisions
about who to hire and who to promote
their company and they then they use
this data as bad as it might be to set
goals where they should be right now
Localytics is
growing rapidly we've we've hired up
many many engineers but we don't have
the resources that Google or Yahoo or
Amazon does yet and so we don't have an
HR department that I can turn to people
who have done studied surveys like this
before and I did what a lot of good
engineers do and I want to stack
overflow and I see my search for anybody
conducting diversity surveys at work I
wanted tips and tricks and I wanted to
know how to conduct these surveys and I
found very very little information so i
wanted to talk a little bit about what
we learned through our own process we
every year at Localytics we have a
hackathon where work stops for three
days and the entire company gets to
focus on what they want to work on and i
thought this was a perfect occasion to
gather a group of like-minded
individuals at Localytics and conduct a
survey i'll talk about three of the
three of the questions we asked that i
think had the most conversation about
them or people are most afraid to ask at
work in hopes that if you want to
conduct a survey like this at your job
this will make it a little easier for
you we talked about ethnicity and race
gender & GLBT affiliation so for
ethnicity and race there are hundreds of
different ethnicities ethnicities and
races and combinations of them and we
wanted to be inclusive we settled on a
government form called the EEO one how
many of you have heard of this form
before okay a few companies with over 50
employees have to fill out this form to
report race and ethnicity to the
government they break it down into six
different ethnicities and races which is
very few I understand um but we thought
it would be the least controversial
option to use the same government form
that we would have to fill out anyway
for gender we wanted to show that you
know give the indication that we're not
thinking about gender in a binary way
it's not just male or female there's
other genders gender is a expression of
who you are it's an identity so we made
it a text box
Facebook takes the tact of they have 51
I think at last count maybe even more
now genders and kudos to them for doing
that the the data scientists and you
might be a little skittish at opentext
box how do you normalize that and we did
have to go through everyone and make
sure that spelling and capitalization
was the same wasn't so bad and then for
GLBT affiliation this is something that
Google and Yahoo and others do not
report on in their official stats and we
wanted to make sure to include these
employees in the survey but I also
didn't want to make the data
identifiable I wanted to be able to
share it with other people and not have
people because we had department as one
of the columns and we didn't want people
to be able to identify exactly who was
who in the survey results so we stuck
with yes or no do you affiliate with
this label GLBT we didn't break it down
further than that my website at the
bottom less read dot me has the full all
the survey questions that we asked if
you want some inspiration on how to do
this for your for your own job these
results by the way of the survey it's
what I bring to hiring managing hiring
manager meetings that's what I bring
when I have one-on-ones with the CEO we
talk about the results internally and we
use them to set goals for hiring fund
you can fund events and meetups that you
think are important to the community so
in Boston there is there was no meet up
for LGBT engineers and I thought there
should be so i made one called code
pride this is from one of the attendees
i was interested in localytics before
but i'm way more excited now that you
host code pride as a hiring manager if i
don't hear this enough I'm not doing my
job I want people to knock down our door
and say I want to come work for
localytics for a lot of different
reasons and one of them is because you
host events like this I had never run a
meetup before so again I did my like
doing my research probably lot of you do
too and so I reached out to a group that
I that was known in Boston for being
very well organized and well run
it's a group called women who code
you've probably heard of that they have
chapters all over the US they jumped on
the chance to meet with me to talk about
starting code pride they met me for
coffee for we SAT there for an hour and
a half we talked about everything from
not being discouraged if only a few
people show up the first time it takes
time to build a community that was great
advice by the way to what do you do for
the first meetup what kinds of meetups
are there and we settled on a meet and
greet I bought some pizza at Localytics
we have beer on tap all the time so that
was easy um to get people to talk have
some beers before meet up and and we
were in our their toll people showed up
we went around in a circle we talked
about who we are professionally
challenges we faced being LGBT in
engineering and elsewhere and it was a
great success I think if you're
interested in using the code pride name
happy to talk to you after this about
spraying it in more cities other than
Boston but we also host outside of
outside events so there's this thing
called she geeks out it's a group of
self professed geeks and they did get
together to talk about geeky things once
a month it's a dinner so they sell
tickets to this dinner and the proceeds
go to science club for girls an
organization in Cambridge Mass and in
other places that gets young women
involved in the STEM fields and we had
150 women show up with a waiting list of
about 50 more that wanted to come we
couldn't unfortunately couldn't we know
the space for that but we bought dinner
and we bought a little giveaways at the
end and we provided one of the two
speakers so our director of product
Sarah she got up and talked to the women
and the CEO of startup Institute in
Boston came to talk it's the right thing
to do to host these events it sends a
signal to your current employees that
you care about this issue sends a signal
to the community that we're we're part
of the community right but the hiring
manager in me also wants is a little
selfish here right I want people to come
through
door I want them to want to work at
Localytics of the hundred and fifty
women we had 40 people write back and
say they wanted to know more about our
open positions they wanted you to know
more about working at localytics that's
40 warm leads of people who want to work
for me I'm doing my job right
something's working raise raise this
issue at work not everybody knows that
they should care about this if you're
here you probably know you should care
about it but the hundred and fifty other
people that work at localytics need to
also know about it and care about it too
so picture this i start in january of
this year at Localytics I don't know
anybody other than my boss in my
immediate co-workers they bring us all
down to mohegan sun casino in
Connecticut for our annual company
meeting it's about an hour and a half
two hours away from Boston it's
everything a casino should be its
shopping it's gambling it's drinking
it's having fun with your co-workers and
over the course of the events there was
a town hall meeting where the CEO got up
in front of us and you know it was a
question to answer kind of event and I
knew this was my chance okay i can i can
ask a question about diversity in front
of these people that i don't know very
well this is gonna be the first thing a
lot of them know about me and the only
thing a lot of them know about me so I
let other people warm the crowd a little
bit ask their questions and I raised my
hand and I asked the CEO what is the
management team doing to address
diversity in the lack of it in the
company and the CEO to his credit you
know instead of course they care about
diversity they know it leads to better
outcomes in a business sense they know
it's the right thing to do and then he
did something I do not expect which he
gave me the microphone back and said
okay Tony what would specifically would
you do at localytics to increase
diversity and I froze it's a very scary
thing right but he taught me a very
important lesson that day which is
nobody needs to give you permission you
don't have to have it as part of your
title in order to advocate for diversity
at work it's not part of my job
description it Localytics to advocate
for diversity it's something that I care
about and others do too so I take up
torch they're very supportive by the way
I mean they're paying for me to come
here across flying across the country to
come talk to you about these issues
that's how much they care about it but
they want somebody to step up they want
those leaders in the company to step up
and care about it too okay the fourth
way is to call out when you hear a
racist joke or somebody use a derogatory
term for women or for gay people or they
talk about Caitlyn Jenner in not nice
terms right call it out make sure that
they know that you are offended by what
they said and you don't have to be a
part of the group that it was directed
at to say something I came out to my
college buddies freshman year of college
and they accepted me but the thing that
showed me that they accepted me and not
just accepted but celebrated me was when
they would hear somebody say oh you know
no homo or or that's so gay right
because we're common terms back back in
the day when I went to college and they
would say hey listen I'm offended by
what you just said right they didn't say
Tony would be offended they were
offended and that's okay to speak out
people are afraid to do this sometimes
because they're afraid of the pushback
they'll get well I'm not racist I just
you know it's just a joke man can't you
take a joke and one of the techniques I
use to get it to to make this an easier
conversation is I first of all I won't
do it in front of a group if they tell
the joke to a group of people wait until
we're in private I find that leads to a
better discussion less defensive and
I'll point out the specific situation
i'll say yesterday when you told that
joke it made me feel very uncomfortable
I didn't appreciate who the joke was
targeted towards you see what I did
there I pointed out a specific situation
and talked about how their behavior had
an impact on me that's a general way of
giving tough feedback to somebody that
way it's not them it's not about them
being racist in general right it's about
a specific thing they said that I didn't
appreciate so you can take that that
lesson and apply it to a lot of
different
difficult conversations you have with
people and finally a recruit if you're
doing your job along the way right you
and you can we've talked about some ways
that I like to recruit people a more
diverse workforce at work and I have
applicants asked me what does it like to
be a woman or a person of color in your
engineering department I'm the kind of
person that I will be honest with them
and I'll say look we struggle with this
like every single other company may be a
part from etsy that I know about right
but we're doing these specific things
about it we're not sitting around
waiting for somebody else to do
something we're trying these different
things and I want you if you come to
work for us I want you to join in the
conversation I wanted to be part of your
job here to help me make a diverse
workforce I fall into the trap where I
think about myself in very binary terms
like a lot of a lot of Engineers fall
into this trap too right I was a
straight A student in college I like to
think that I'm really good at my job but
this binary way of thinking either
doesn't leave a lot of room for
improvement I'm great I don't need to
improve upon it or I'm not good at that
so I won't even try there's too high of
a start-up costs right I think a lot of
people think about diversity in this
sense I'm not good at it so I won't try
out let somebody else do it where I'm
great at it not nothing else to learn
about it I tend to think about my own
journey more like this a trend I have
highs and lows maybe I just hosted a
fantastic dinner for women to get into
engineering that's a high or I had a low
maybe I didn't I didn't say something
about a racist joke over her to work but
over time those loads become less
frequent and those highs get even higher
encourage you to think about your
diversity efforts this way it's not hard
to get started try something and you'll
learn from it it's the same thing we use
right to develop our projects is an
agile iterative approach how many of us
build perfect system is the first time
we've set out to build them did I see a
hand no
uh I don't I I don't write I need to try
some things that work get rid of the
things that don't and keep moving ok
back to my flight I did get on it I did
not get kicked off thank goodness it was
a weekend of ups and downs for us
meeting senator senator Santorum was a
Down definitely my husband and I boarded
the plane in Boston married for two
years we boarded married and we landed
in Omaha Nebraska legally strangers not
married another down for us right but
what gives me such great hope is that no
joke literally less than 24 hours after
we met Santorum the Supreme Court handed
down the ruling getting marriage
equality across the land right this was
that was like tremendous up in Omaha
Nebraska of all places it was the first
time I felt like a fool American citizen
which sounds dramatic but it's not I can
participate in federal government
incentives right I felt accepted and
celebrated in my own country for the
first time I see a similar progressive
upward path for engineering departments
it doesn't have to be this way it didn't
always used to be this way all it takes
is people like you and me to just try
thank
questions comments yes I love Elena
they're super great people and worked a
lot with Rainbow PUSH as well hmm i
think it's great to provide these forums
where people who have similar
backgrounds and the same perspective can
commiserate with each other for each
other yeah that's not you all start it
that's not really a model of the
solution to model the solution me to
create environments in which we have
gender parity we have the right
representation of people of other
backgrounds as well in between any
examples of success in mapping of
modeling the environment that we want to
ultimately achieve you asking about like
companies that live and breathe these
these values and to have a diverse
workforce already yeah i think i
mentioned etsy a little bit they've made
some great strides with women
specifically i don't i can't remember
the exact numbers i don't think they're
that parody yet but they're they're way
closer than eighteen percent let me see
if i can remember i think they funded no
i think it's okay to be honest with you
in my experience these are the coding
boot camps like the rails coding boot
camp so i'm not sure if i think they
exist for python communities as well
have much better parity in terms of
women in people of color represented
right better than better than some of
the computer science programs that i've
seen out of schools and i think etsy
funded one of those like they
specifically funded a grant a grant type
program for people to then move out of
that program and work at etsy it's a
longer term it's these are not quick I
mean I've only been at localytics for
seven months so you know these are not
quick hits they're not like Oh
immediately tomorrow we have half you
know half women but thanks yeah I was
wondering do you think that Perry could
almost be like the wrong metric to like
optimize on that it could be like cargo
cultic in this sense that Lee I saw like
a dashboard a diversity dashboard that
was put off and I was discussing it with
my wife and she said you know they
should put that on the actual like job
application because it shouldn't be like
a one-way power flow essentially where
you know as the company we're using you
the applicant the diverse applicant you
know to meet our metric goal so if do
you think that the parity is actually
like if we achieve parity now we're
diverse and that maybe it's like the
wrong metric per se you know or it's bad
to have that you know as the metric of
diversity um I'm trying to repeat the
question if is parity like could it just
be that that's like a symptom of a
diverse work environment rather than
like that's what will cause diversity in
a team parody is this 20 it's like a
like a comes out of a diverse work
environment Chrissy's like diverse work
environment this is a this is what we
want to happen this is a good outcome
but if we optimized for this
specifically then we may kind of Miss
the reasons why diversity is good we
unintentionally create bad power
structures that are are like your
tokenized basically for example yeah I
can turn to you guys I don't have the
answers there that's an interesting
thought is it yeah I mean I think about
my friend my friend Terran tonight I
went to WPI in western Massachusetts we
stuck jokingly call ourselves the tokens
at some of these events like we were the
gay and the african-american invited to
the been SIA it's a risk
always right um yeah we you're right we
don't have like we don't set numerical
targets when we talk about hiring but I
bring up the the data that I do have to
show that we're not where we want to be
right we're not where we should be yes
Oh have you seen this graph by NPR
earlier this year I know it doesn't have
everything on there but this tracks
Medical School in law school and
physical sciences as well right and this
is what i mean by in the 80s it wasn't
always this way and there's lots of
there's theories about why this happened
some of which deals with how computers
were marketed in the 80s to two boys
right and that's probably one of many
confounding factors I'm sure but that's
probably part of the conversation with
you right like is I wonder if it was
always that way for some of those other
disciplines yeah coming
do you have any examples of like you
know the silent majority is usually you
don't realize it's a problem you know
empowering those people and building
that awareness a little but I mean if
they're not here in this room you know
besides etsy is a really good example
I'm going to look that up yeah are you
any other sort of like case studies and
things that we could study or encouraged
by in terms of yes studies to encourage
you um I mention I didn't cite the
source but I mentioned the Harvard
Business School study about diverse
teams performing better at decision
making that's definitely one of them
there is also there are so some studies
about companies headed by women beating
the market more than company is headed
by men and i wish i wish i had the
actual citation for you but i'm sure
that it will come up search for it those
were all in the past few months they all
came out recently yes in the back yep
yes yeah
yep
that's great I mean I'm a very
collaborative leader I don't like the on
high kind of style anyway so my style is
to talk about talk about this raise it
in casual conversation with people make
it top of mind but I like what you said
there's also a business case for that
too I mentioned my company deals with
30,000 apps in the App Store some of
which are directed specifically at GLBT
communities some of which were directed
specifically at women right and so you
need to have people on your team to
understand those communities if you're
going to build the best product you can
build and if you're going to sell to
them anymore quite this is a great
conversation great I'll be available
outside for any more questions thanks to
everyone for coming